speaking of royalty over the years many
actresses have played and portrayed
queen elizabeth the first in tv in
movies some of your favorites might come
to mind think about performances of
icons like margot robbie kate blanchette
and helen marin now we've got a new
favorite to add to your list alicia von
rittberg she takes on the monarch's
early years in the new stars tv show
becoming elizabeth the story begins
after the death of king henry viii when
the princess is thrown into the turmoil
and intrigue of the english court in
this clip her younger brother king
edward tells her that a danish prince is
coming to meet and marry her for a
political alliance take a look
the marriage of convenience indeed
so they come here to view their goods
before buying
do you reckon me 15 or 16 handsets look
you're quite pretty
i'd have thought you'd be happy to meet
a man before you married him no one's
going to let me meet the scottish girl
when it was set on me to wet her she was
a five-year-old
she would have been a stranger to the
school you could have locked her in a
cupboard if you so wanted but i will be
the stranger i'm not going to lock you
in a cupboard
don't make me edward
please
alicia von rittberg joins us right now
how are you doing i'm good thanks for
having me thank you for joining us now
you took several classes and lessons to
embody the young princess elizabeth um
you call those princess classes
but what did you learn exactly um well
basically i think it started with
dialect coaching um i've been working on
a british accent for one year i think in
total because you're german because i'm
german yeah yeah yeah um and then horse
riding i've never been on halls before
um
playing the virginals which is the old
piano
um calligraphy with a like proper quill
and um yeah color so you're german
you're also a countess which is a
category i don't understand but did it
give you any technical insight into a
princess no i don't i don't understand
it either
i wish i wish but it didn't really
didn't help no so what is a countess
exactly well it's just a name to be
honest it's just like a leftover from
here is there a card in your wallet like
can you park anywhere and put a little
thing i gotta i got horses in front of
my house and there's
special privileges but let's talk about
your accent because you were you were uh
your native tongue is german so how did
you perfect the english accent what did
you do to prepare for that
well um
funnily enough we didn't really
concentrate on the lines but actually
you have to get to a point where you
could improvise in a british accent and
to be completely comfortable with it and
we were looking at other people that
would have the perfect accent to kind of
like adapt who was that for you who was
that um and for me it was kate winslet
actually
we thought that she has like the most
beautiful neutral um british accent and
um we found audio books that she had
recorded like actually children audio
books like the far far away tree by
royal dahl
so i would constantly have like a flag
in my ear and listen to kate winslet
reading that book to me but look at all
the cool stuff you had to learn though i
think calligraphy is so pretty it really
is
it really is no on invitations it's so
it looks tough to do though yeah is it
like you wouldn't want to have like a
closer look at what i actually did
because i'd
not have enough time for that it's just
like
i'm a mess and riding a horse for the
first time and but the storyline about
young the young queen and her siblings
her brother seems quite obnoxious edward
talk about the dynamic what did you
learn about the family mm-hmm well i
think with this we
um
very much tried and like the showrunner
aniari is like i think what was so
brilliant about her books that she tried
to concentrate on the human
relationships like on
on the humans and the people behind
those like figures we know from the
books so it was so important to us to
actually show the love and the bond that
comes from growing up together as well
rather than just like the challenges and
the
things they had to face like due to
their duty
um and i think never to forget that
there is always love as well and that
it's more than just like yeah
the queen's life in the royal family
have been well documented so it seems
like we know a lot about them but if you
could ask the queen one question what
would it be
well i think i would i would love to
know know if she would would have wanted
to be queen um
that's a good question
because i don't know i i i i can't tell
if uh it's just something you grew up
with so you have no choice or if at some
point she was like
might as well might as well
you know what if you were in that
position would you want to be queen
after after portraying her
and understanding what she wanted i
think i wouldn't want to i think it's
such a burden um i don't know if i would
want that burden on my shoulders how fun
was it to be 28 and play a 14 year old
and and you dyed your hair red
yeah
very much became a um yeah it almost
started to grow out red at some point
because i died so i we we love stars in
our house the the network uh we watched
all of outlander this is going to be a
delicious series i'm confident we're
going to consume all of it uh
part of what's fun about it is the
costumes and also the the the realism
you only shot with candles and natural
light do i have that right i think the
candles i need a van to look 14 as well
it is but but you're right it's like it
was like it was so immersive it was like
they built that world it was all natural
light it was like
you you could like shoot in a 360 degree
way
and wouldn't catch a single like like i
don't know
stand or something because it was all
candles and and and real you could touch
everything you could use everything yeah
and i think that made it so like it was
for us actors it was the dream it was
yeah a completely immersive experience
yeah you know what elizabeth yeah that
would not be my dream that we only shot
by candles
so trouble when we blew our nostrils at
night
it was black oh wow yes it was like
that's a great deal well alicia ronald
berg thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me